Steve says I find myself agreeing with
much of Aristotle's thoughts on ethics I
wish I was exposed to these when I was
younger don't we all
although it's interesting because
so I mean I was exposed to Aristotle as
an undergraduate and I mistakenly
thought that Aristotle wasn't saying
anything really interesting so I wasn't
in a proper condition myself to make use
of what I was getting from Aristotle
until really in graduate school but
assuming that you had your head on
better than I did as a younger person
maybe encountering Aristotle earlier on
would be helpful and I will say
something that um Aleister McIntyre he's
got a piece called plain persons and
moral philosophy that when I teach an
ethics class I often begin with that
and he makes the point that you can't
just like go to young people and say
here you go here's Aristotle's Nick and
McCain ethics uh go go forth and prosper
young person
you got to do a lot of unpacking and
explaining and you know back and forth
dialogue and stuff like that because you
know you you look at what Aristotle's
saying
um it's not in a form that I think most
young people Eric McIntyre was saying
this back in like the 1980s I think or
1990s
it's even more so for today it would be
hard to like just like throw
Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics into
the lap of a young person and say now
you've got the blueprint for how to
behave
but they're certainly better off
encountering Aristotle or Plato or the
stoics than than not right and for a lot
of us this is not stuff that we get in
our um kindergarten through 12th grade
and if we get it in college it's usually
in the context of an ethics class or an
intro to philosophy class
um and it's you know maybe it's taught
well maybe it's not I mean my teachers
were pretty terrible as an undergraduate
so so that's yeah I mean I I agree with
you too on that any
Steve does Aristotle equate virtue with
goodness or is goodness something
different for him neither
um
it's it's better to view virtue as a
main kind of goodness it is not the only
kind of goodness
um but it is among the most important
kinds of goodness and it's certainly the
one that makes other good things for us
human beings
work right so what do I mean by that
there's there's really two things to say
so
um Aristotle distinguishes can pretty
consistently in his Works between uh
different types of goodness and and
correspondingly Badness right so for
example in Nico McCann ethics book one
he's going to distinguish between
um good as being like just and unjust so
that's one modality the we can call it
beautiful or fine or honorable the
cologne and the shameful the ice Throne
not the same thing as Justice and
Injustice although there sometimes is is
overlap the useful the some Ferron and
the harmful the blabaron notice we've
already got like three different things
going on here and none of them are
reducible to each other and then we have
the pleasurable and the painful
Aristotle considers pleasure to be a
good pain to be a bad but that's yet
another modality of goodness and Badness
and we can also use sort of a generic
term you know agathon for goods all
these these kinds of goods and um [ __ ]
on for bads and then we can talk not
just about these values or or modalities
we can talk about actual things like
wealth is a useful good right wealth is
not a pleasant good unless you're like
super into wealth and you know that
makes you feel good to have money in the
bank
um then there's there's useful Goods you
know and then I mean other useful goods
and there's Pleasant goods and then
there's things that are noble and virtue
figures into that virtue also as we're
going to see when we talk about this in
two weeks makes us just because Justice
as a whole
includes the virtues as a matter of fact
you can think of uh justice as complete
virtue that's one of the many different
kinds of virtue so Aristotle doesn't
equate virtue with goodness but virtue
is among the main goods for for human
beings and human life you know not so
much unless we're using virtue and
extenuated sense uh for say animals or
plants or stuff like that but you know
moral virtues are actually good for us
and they make us good
um goodness is not something different
from virtue because it includes virtue
but goodness includes a lot of other
kinds of goods so you know Pleasant
experiences
um as we're going to talk about here
honor is is a a good thing according to
Aristotle as well so that's a that's a
good question important clarification to
make any
so Nicole has a good question here how
would somebody move towards claiming
enough or claiming less if they're
claiming more
um so the person is claiming more too
much right perhaps and then how do they
move towards uh claiming less or
claiming the the right amount well
that's a good question so this is where
I would say
this is where we have to go beyond
Aristotle's
um
tax to some degree because if you think
back to our first week like how do we
become virtuous
Aristotle says that a lot of it is
through habituation
um now
habituation in a lot of cases is going
to be like rehabituation because if
we're already so you know this person
that Nicole is bringing up
hypothetically maybe they're a little
bit foolish or Vain and we want to bring
them back to a right recognition of what
it is that they actually deserve that's
not going to happen through them just
like reading a book or having somebody
say in their coaching session you need
to do this it's going to take like
re-thinking it uh approaching these
sorts of things in situation after
situation it'll probably also require
some some role modeling where you look
at people who are genuinely great sold
and you say how are how is what they're
doing different than what you're doing
and how do you move towards that and and
perhaps
um with some of the criteria that
Aristotle is providing us you could do
this cognitively as well you could say
well here's a great example so in quite
a few families in our present day
there may be some people who are given
greater respect or deference or whatever
we want to call it Greater status within
the family than they actually deserve
and then there's other people who get
less if you're that person who's who's
getting more than you actually deserve
you could in fact think to yourself
um why is it that you know
my relatives are always treating me as
The Golden Child right uh wow look at
this you know they went they went and
ran at a track meet oh this is so
amazing whereas like you know uh Jimmy
or Jenny over there is just like won a
scholarship to Yale and they're not
being celebrated right you could like
look at that and be like things are
things are screwed up here I need to
figure out how I myself am not just
going to bask in their adulation but I'm
gonna demand the right amount and maybe
like shift some of my honor that I'm
getting to
um my my siblings who are more squared
away than I am so there's there's a lot
of ways I think that one one could do
this
um let's hold on to that and maybe we'll
come back to that in a bit because I
think there could be other ways that
could be quite helpful as well
all right so here's a good question from
David where we're getting a little bit
more specific would the magnanimous
person wait to be asked for their loves
or hates or would they actively look for
ways to share their opinions
so that's uh I don't think that they
would actively look for ways to share
their opinions unless they were like in
a crisis and they wanted to use that
opportunity to to like really take a
stand so
if somebody is like this politician who
is our governor or Senator or this this
person who's in charge of our
organization or this person who's our
our you know CEO is really screwing up
I'm gonna take a stand and do it so
deliberately I think that that would be
possible but those will be extraordinary
circumstances
I don't think that they'll
always wait to be asked
um but they're probably going to be
more reticent
to
um come right out about it I mean
they're not gonna like you know stop a
meeting to say I think that's BS you
know or this is a really awesome you
know
um I think they're going to be we could
say I think they're going to be
strategic
in their public Revelations of their
loves and and hates
um you know a great example of this is
somebody who I would say is magnanimous
in this way is Aleister McIntyre if you
don't know who he is he's a uh very
important 20th and 21st century virtue
ethics philosopher who started out uh
being analytically trained and um as a
Marxist made his way as a cultural
critic eventually became an aristillion
and then you know sort of a more robust
um uh version of that and what we call
Aristotelian tomeism and I was fortunate
enough to be in a faculty
um Fellowship over the summer with
Aleister McIntyre in 2000
five
at Notre Dame University and I was
probably the most Junior scholar
selected for that and you know we got to
interact
um quite a bit and
um
he and I would have conversations once
in a while
I would see him at conferences and he
was not what you would call a respecter
of persons meaning that he didn't like
only hang out with the big shots he
would hang out with with nobody's like
me and you know he'd come up and he'd be
like how are your wife and kids and what
are you what are you working on right
now and you know he wrote a letter of
recommendation for me that was very
helpful in looking for jobs and
um that's that's the kind of guy that he
is he's he walks the Walk of virtue
ethics and he could another great
example of how he was magnanimous as a
teacher when he was at uh Notre Dame
before he retired I mean he's in his 90s
now
um he could have only taught graduate
students or not even taught anybody he
could have just done research and talks
and stuff like that
instead he chose to teach undergraduates
in basic classes like intro to
philosophy and why did he do that he
said well they deserve a good education
too
and they're where you know we have the
greatest opportunity to do some good
graduate students are easy to teach
undergraduates much more difficult to
teach and I I you know I looked at that
and I was like wow that's a guy who
really follows his principles now the
frankness of speech so McIntyre talks
about there's a phrase in after virtue
the bat you know Saint Benedict right
and it got turned into this thing called
the Benedict option by uh a guy named
Rod rare
and you know advocated by a lot of
cultural conservatives and McIntyre
um took the opportunity in one of his
recent addresses to say people have like
you know tried to claim that I'm putting
forth something like that and this is
directly opposed to what I'm actually uh
teaching so he was showing his his in
Aristotelian terms his hatred very
publicly uh but doing so strategically
so I think to to you know finish David's
question it's really going to depend on
the situation that the magnanimous is in
um they're not going to be like you know
the person who's just waiting for the
conversation to have a law in it so they
can like put their own thing in there
they're not looking for that kind of
social status so that's that's an
important uh consideration
Steve says why does Aristotle say
smallness of soul is worse than vanity
at least that's my translation second to
last sentence of chapter three well
let's take a look at that because that
doesn't sound quite right it probably
says uh worse in some uh respect right
um so what I have here is smallness of
soul is more opposed than vanity to
Greatness of Soul being both uh more
prevalent and worse so let's see what
the Greek is here
um Auntie Theta so opposed the tape
megala pursue
so that's that's right there
[Music]
um
it happens more often
esteem I mean it could be worse
um is can also be lesser
um so it's kind of a translator's choice
I would say there but I don't think it's
conveying that as a disposition it's
it's actually like more vicious
um it's not kakistos you know so
yeah but what what's his reasoning there
um
maybe it deviates more from uh greatness
of soul
then vanity does the vain person is uh
it's sort of like the the rash person
with courage and then cowardice right
the rash person is also a screw-up just
like the coward is but it looks more
similar to
to the uh The Virtue so
um George says I do see myself as small
sold I usually shoot myself down over
certain skills which is bad because this
judgment becomes internalized to who I
am but it is overall mistaken yeah it
it's it is bad for you overall
[Music]
and as a pattern
and it it you know it eventually becomes
part of your mindset so you start out by
like being self-deprecating and then
eventually you do think of yourself that
way right that can happen so he says
I've gotten a good grade in philosophy
courses students in my classes have
asked me questions over something
they're confused about but nevertheless
I don't see myself as capable of
Performing well in philosophy last
semester I did a paper for my gender in
Sociology class
and as soon as I turned it in for some
reason I thought I was going to fail
I started thinking about the
consequences of failing and
internalizing them but I actually did
pretty well fear has a big role to play
here and fear can override reasonable
counter arguments against it I guess I
have to train myself against fear so a
lot a lot of different things going on
there
um
you know Aristotle doesn't talk about
fear in this section but I think what
George is bringing up which is an
experience that I think many of us have
had in one way or another it could be
about education it could be about our
job prospects
um you know I'll tell you that one thing
that's that took a lot of work on my
part when I first started working with
uh clients and you know having to like
you know be a marketer and close deals
is the reluctance to ask people for
money right because you you don't want
to get to that point where they're going
to turn you down
um or try to you know can't you do it
for cheaper or something like that so
sometimes you don't talk about it at all
right and you let them bring it up in
which case sometimes they never bring it
up it requires overcoming that fear and
what is the fear of the fear is of
you know what we talked about a little
bit earlier this being refuted or being
revealed as not being as good as as
you're presenting yourself as being in
in the case of like dealing with clients
maybe my services are not worth the
money that I'm asking for right and
they'll say screw you I'm not going to
give it to you maybe in the case of a
paper you're handing it in and your
worry is they're going to see that I'm
I'm a fraud and I don't know what I'm
talking about they're going to give me
an f and it'll have a big f on it and
they'll hand it to me in front of the
whole class they don't do that really
anymore but
um
or at least they shouldn't because
that's kind of a jerk thing to do and we
could talk about this in in many other
uh forms so it you know if you know so
if you think of yourself as small sold
and this kind of goes back to the
question that I think I think it might
have been Nicole asked earlier yeah how
does somebody move towards claiming the
right amount
um so if you're small sold then like you
said training yourself how do you how do
you move yourself to the middle position
where you are in fact
demanding expecting
um
rightly assessing what you're worth
what what your value is uh takes a lot
of work and you might have to you might
have to do cognitive exercises like it's
good that you've identified that fear is
a factor there and you can you can do
exercises Aristotle doesn't give you
exercises but you could do exercises
like those in other philosophies of life
and look at your fears and
um you know unravel them cognitively and
figure out whether they're reasonable
fears or not right so that's that's a
that's a great point
sure so now let's answer Nicole's
question let's talk about this fourth
possibility
so in the nick of McCain ethics
the person who's worthy of little and
claims little Aristotle says is
temperate Soul throne and he also says
something else that's kind of kind of
funny
he says that it's like a small person
who can't really be attractive a person
with a small body they can't really be
attractive in a full sense because that
involves largeness now
I don't know about this this doesn't
even seem like culturally conditioned
this seems like Aristotle thinks that
bigger people are more attractive now we
know that there's some things to this
right if you're if you're tall I I've
been fortunate enough to enjoy what we
could call tall privilege it turns out
that
um being tall puts you at certain
advantages for things but does it
actually make you more attractive I I
don't know about that
um
so you know Aristotle's saying this is
not a great disposition but it's okay to
have
in the udemian ethics where he does not
by the way talk about right ambition he
says that
um there are small things that a person
may deserve and claim uh things of the
size this person is not reprehensible
they're not bad
and they're also not the opposite of the
great sold person
the smallest old person is the opposite
they're they're at a a vice end right
the vain person is another opposite
this person
so like what Nicole was asking what's
the difference between the small person
and humbleness
um The Humble person
realizes that they don't deserve a lot
and they don't they don't demand a lot
as a result they know their their value
um they're they're not lacking
self-knowledge you could say whereas the
small sold person really does deserve
more than they're claiming
and they're maybe putting themselves
down or they are you know as George was
saying you know driven by fear or you
know Aristotle would say
um they just don't know their own value
and so there's there's a difference
between these two
um kinds of dispositions now
interestingly
this nameless value right ambition as
we're calling it
um it's discussed in the nick of McCain
ethics briefly but not not at Great
length and it's not discussed in the
um
udemian ethics at all
in the nick of McCain ethics this middle
state is as Aristotle says nameless
so
why is it nameless or well you know
people know the extremes but there's no
name for the right mean and Aristotle
says there is a mean when it comes to
this that causes us to be rightly
disposed uh deitati towards moderate and
small honors and what are moderate and
small honors you know like people
remembering our birthday or
um you know giving us
uh you know congratulations about a job
that we got or pick whatever else you
you want to say and he says that we can
desire in Greek or sometimes translated
as pursue honor more or less than is
right right failure from the right or
wrong sources whole thing which could be
the right or wrong people but also the
right or wrong
um reasons
and in the right or wrong ways
um hosts in in Greek right and he says
that
um on the two extremes we have two terms
we have the ambitious person the
filotimos the lover of Honor right
and we criticize a person
for being ambitious if they seek honor
more than is right or from the wrong
sources
um so the people who are constantly
trying to you know increase their their
social media presence but they don't
really have much to say or the people
who are always trying to be a big shot
at work but they don't really pull their
load you know
um and then he says likewise
a person gets criticized as being
unambitious when they don't care is how
it's translated here but the the Greek
for that is actually
and so it's coming from that races
um they don't
um prioritize you could say uh being
honored even for things that are good
even for things that are beautiful or
Noble Epi toys
so you know like if you are a good
musician and you know you're at a party
and people are like hey would you play
us a song and you're like oh no no
no I can't do that sort of thing my my
singing sucks you know you're being
unambitious in that respect and you
might also be being small sold but we
gotta ask right is this about something
big or is this about something minor
uh George says I think I could think of
someone who depends on their job they
should demand a larger wage but they
don't want to lose their job yeah I mean
that's
if you push too hard right that would be
an issue Oh Nicole
okay so Nicole has a good point here
seems in our culture ambition developed
as a negative association as though it's
equal to dominance and exploitation
the result is a tsunami of small sold
people time to claim what we deserve
yeah and this is the challenge right to
figure out
given that we've been given
um wrong assessments of value
from perhaps people in our family and it
could be too high too low and then in
school and then in the workplace and
then in the general culture
um how do we figure out what we really
do deserve and then how do we go about
um demanding it like George was was
pointing out fear can can stand in the
way of demanding what we actually
deserve and I think I think you're right
that there is
um a lot there are a lot of people who
are we could from Aristotelian point of
view small sold and don't have to be so
but they're kind of stuck
in that and you know we often talk in
terms of like low self-esteem or stuff
like that but I think we can translate
that
into this
um this question of ambition on the
other hand there are other people that
are pushed to be very ambitious and
maybe go to to too much of an extreme
you know if you are from a wealthy
family or a family that has power family
as we say that has juice has clout
um you're probably going to be pushed to
you know assert yourself more than
somebody who comes from a uh the other
side of the tracks as we say right I
oh so this is interesting
um Nicole says
assertiveness training seems to be great
towards moving uh towards claiming that
which you deserve I think you're right
about that I mean assertiveness training
encompasses a bit more than that right
because like typically you distinguish
between
passivity aggressivity and then
assertiveness so like you know if people
are making you angry you being assertive
means like saying I'm getting angry with
you because you violated this boundary
that I told you about and you know uh
but I'm not gonna like blow up and knock
stuff off the desk and things like that
but it's also not like uh just just
tamping it down so assertiveness
training could be for anger it could be
for uh great solidness or right ambition
would it pertain to any others I think
um some of the ones that we're going to
look at next week
because there's this virtue of like
truthfulness or sincerity about the self
I think assertiveness training could
probably help with that too
and and also with the virtue of
friendliness because the virtue of
friendliness requires us sometimes to
lay down limits and say I'm not going to
do that with you I'm not gonna I'm not
going to co-sign your BS uh to some
people and assertiveness is is uh needed
for that so that that's a that's a great
Point
um
Oh Nicole has a really great suggestion
an idea for the nameless middle proper
assertiveness
I I yeah that's a great idea I like that
um that's something worth trying to get
out there uh
to the Aristotle people as a matter